ستة أمتار
، رائع ، أود أن أقول أه عودة إلى العلم
، النتيجة النهائية
التي تعتبر مهمة حقًا من هذه
المهمة هي أننا توقعنا أن يبدو هذا الكويكب
رمليًا وشبيهًا بالشاطئ ، وكان ذلك بناءً
على الخصائص الحرارية التي تحددها
الملاحظات التلسكوبية من الأرض
ووصلنا إلى هناك واستخدمنا مطياف otis
nrovir لرسم خريطة
وإنتاج توصيف القصور الذاتي الحراري
للسطح بأكمله
وقلب كل شيء نفسه رأسًا على عقب
بناءً على
نماذجنا ، المناطق التي اعتقدنا أنها ستكون
شبيهة بالشاطئ بناءً على الخصائص الحرارية التي
تحولت إلى  تكون أكبر الصخور على
سطح الكويكب ، واتضح أن المناطق الأكثر
دقة في الحبيبات
تحتوي على ما نطلق عليه
هذا القصور الذاتي الحراري العالي
تمامًا على عكس كل ما كنا
نتوقعه ينتشر الكثير من العلوم العظيمة
نتيجة لذلك ، وبالتالي عندما تذكر أن
هناك  هذه الصخور البراقة من فيستا
هل هذا
يعني أن بينو كان ذات مرة في
حزام الكويكبات بين
المريخ والمشتري  يُعد t
bennu حاليًا كويكبًا قريبًا من الأرض ،
لكن لديه مؤخرًا
تجولًا في النظام الشمسي الداخلي ، نعتقد في
الواقع أنه
شظايا من كويكب أكبر
بكثير تم تعطيله بشكل كارثي
ربما منذ مليار سنة ، واو هذا رائع جدًا ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك
حسنًا ، الآن يمثل تحديًا مثل
الحصول على بينو التقاط
عينة من الكويكب شيء آخر
تمامًا
والفريق بحاجة إلى تطوير هذا
النظام الرائع ، حيث كانت مهمة أوزيريس ركس
قيد التطوير منذ ما يقرب من 20
عامًا مع المهندسين والعلماء الذين
يطورون جديدًا  التقنيات
والاستراتيجيات لإنجاز شيء
لم يتم القيام به من قبل بصراحة وهذا يمثل
تحديًا خاصًا لأن بينو
لديه مجال جاذبية ضعيف ،
لذلك عندما تفكر في الذهاب إلى مدار
حول شيء ما ، يمكنك أن تدور حول
شيء لا تستطيع الجاذبية
الإمساك به وفي الواقع  يدفعك إلى
المدار ، الأمر كله يتعلق بتحليق
المركبة الفضائية
، كما أنه من الصعب جدًا أخذ
عينة في غضون  بيئة منخفضة الجاذبية ،
لحسن الحظ ، لدينا العقل المدبر
وراء الجهاز الذي
سيأخذ العينة الليلة.
للحصول على عينة
لأنك قد تعتقد نوعًا ما في البداية يمكنك
فقط أن تأخذ مثل مخلب
آلي أو ذراع آلية وتلتقط شيئًا ما
ولكن هذا لن ينجح في هذه
الظروف
التي هي بالضبط الجاذبية الصغرى
لبينو توفر تحديًا
لأخذ العينات  لا تواجهك عادة على
الأرض ، يمكنك أن تتخيل محاولة استخدام
مجرفة أو مغرفة
على الأرض وتدفعك الأرض ضدك
ولكن الجاذبية تبقيك على الأرض
بينو ، فإن جاذبية السطح
أقل بآلاف المرات مما هي عليه على
الأرض  إذا دفعت مجرفة أو مغرفة
في الأرض ، فستدفع
نفسك بعيدًا عن السطح ،
لذلك كان علينا التوصل إلى
تقنية تعمل مع هذه الجاذبية المنخفضة جدًا
كان لدينا أيضًا التحدي المتمثل في عدم اليقين
في الخواص الميكانيكية
للسطح وكلا هذين الأمرين جعل الهبوط
تحديًا لن نعرف كيف
نتعامل معه جيدًا بشكل خاص
في هذه المادة ، لذلك كان علينا التوصل
إلى تقنية تعمل في
الجاذبية الصغرى
البيئة والتي يمكن أن تعمل في
بنية العلامة هذه ، هذه الهندسة المعمارية ذات اللمسة
والانطلاق لبضع ثوانٍ فقط
الآن أفهم أنك أحضرت معك بعض
النماذج من المركبة
الفضائية والأداة التي
ستأخذ العينة ، لذا
أظهر لنا ما أنت  لقد وصلنا هنا وهذا
صحيح تمامًا ، لذا هذا نموذج
مصغر للمركبة الفضائية
، حيث يتم تمديد الذراع في موضع أخذ العينات
جزئيًا أسفل الذراع ، يمكنك رؤية ثلاث
زجاجات غاز سنستخدم إحداها
اليوم تحتوي على غاز نيتروجين عالي الضغط
يمر  أسفل الذراع
إلى رأس علامة سام نفسها ، وهنا
لدي بالفعل
علامة ذات مقياس كامل ، إنه في الواقع
جهاز استخدمناه لاختبار التجميع
على الأرض
، ينزل الغاز عني  ليس لدينا
الأنبوب هنا لتظهر لك ، لكن الغاز
ينزل إلى مركز العلامة ،
ينقسم إلى قسمين ويمر
تحت الرأس ،
يوجد الآن فقاعة ضغط مرتفع من
الغاز أسفل الرأس تقوم
بتعبئة
المواد مثل هبوب الرياح إلى حد كبير  الأوساخ في يوم مليء بالأتربة
على
الأرض ونحن محاطون بفراغ
الفضاء ، لذا فإن الغاز
يوجد غاز ضغط عالٍ تحت
علامة سام وسوف يهرب
إلى بيئة الضغط المنخفض
للفراغ في الفضاء المحيط
به ويفعل ذلك  من خلال هذه الشاشة
حول المحيط الكامل لعلامة
سام الرأس نفسها ،
ولكن بينما يمكن للغاز الهروب من الشاشة ،
يحبس المواد بداخلها بأمان ،
إلا أن أحد هذه الأشياء الرائعة
حول هندسة الفضاء هو
الحصول على أشياء
مبنية حقًا بشكل صارم وهي
لا يمكن كسرها بسهولة ولذا
لا توجد أي أجزاء متحركة
هنا وأنت تستخدم فراغ الفضاء
نفسه لتوفير الضغط
لجمع العينة التي كانت مناسبة تمامًا
عندما كنا  أول تصميم لهذا الجهاز
منذ عدة سنوات ، كنا نفكر في أننا
نريد إبقائه بسيطًا
وقويًا ودليلًا كاملاً قدر الإمكان ،
لم نكن نريد أي آليات لم نكن
نريدها أي أجهزة كهربائية ،
فالمجموعة بأكملها مدفوعة
بديناميات  الغاز نفسه ،
وبمجرد إطلاق الغاز من
الزجاجة وانتقاله إلى أسفل الذراع ،
يقوم الغاز بكل العمل الرائع
جدًا ، لذا ما حجم الجسيمات التي نتحدث
عنها هنا ،
حيث تم تصميم علامات جيدة لتجميع جزيئين من
السنتيمتر
ولدي بعض الأمثلة  هنا لتظهر
لك ، فهذه كرة بسماكة 2 سم
، وهي تقريبًا نفس قطر النيكل
ولكن بالطبع معظم المواد الجيولوجية
ليست في الواقع مجالات مثالية معظم
المواد الجيولوجية غير منتظمة
الشكل
وقد عالجت orex موضع صورتها التالية
غير المؤكدة
0.5 متر أوه ذلك  رائع ،
لذلك نحن ذاهبون إلى حيث نحتاج
إلى الذهاب للحصول على هذه المادة ،
لذا فإن معظم المواد الجيولوجية
تتشكل بشكل غير منتظم ، لذا فإن هذه
الصخرة في الواقع تدور حول  يبلغ طوله أربعة
سنتيمترات في أطول أبعاده ، لكننا
ما زلنا قادرين على جمع هذا في
اختبار على الأرض
، وذلك لأنه على الرغم من أنه أربعة
سنتيمترات في هذا البعد ،
يمكنك أن ترى أنه أقل بكثير من
سنتيمترين في هذا البعد
أو حتى سنتيمترين في  بعد آخر ،
لذلك
بينما نحن مقيدون في
اتجاه واحد لسنتيمتر طالما أن
الاتجاهين الآخرين أقل ،
يمكننا في الواقع جمع جزيئات أكبر بكثير
في العلامة ، رأس سام نفسه
ممتاز جيدًا لذلك أفهم أن لدينا
بعض الرسوم المتحركة في قائمة الانتظار حتى  تعطينا
فكرة عما سيحدث في
الكويكب الليلة
شيء مؤكد ،
لذا فإن ما تراه هو أن المركبة الفضائية
تهبط بسرعة 10 سنتيمترات
في الثانية على السطح
أبطأ 15 مرة من سرعة المشي ، فإنها
تلامس حواس المركبة الفضائية وتطلق
الغاز يحرك الغاز المواد أسفل
رأس سام العلامة
بحيث يتسرب الغاز إلى فراغ
الفضاء عبر المحيط
وتتجمع المواد  إد داخل رأس العلامة سام
، تطلق المركبة الفضائية دافعاتها وظهرها
بأمان بعيدًا عن
سطح الكويكب
جيدًا ، شكرًا لك على البرنامج التعليمي على الرغم من أنني
أعني بوضوح أن المجتمع العلمي
سيكون متحمسًا جدًا لدراسة
أي علامة يجمعها سام ، لذا
شكرًا لك على ذلك  شكرًا جزيلاً لك ، إنه لأمر
رائع أن أكون هنا
حسنًا ، حسنًا ، أتحدث جيدًا عن كل
العلامات المهمة ، الشيء الذي يحدث في أقل
من ساعة ،
آه الآن قبل أن نصل إليه لاحقًا ،
سيكون الوقت المناسب لنا للقيام
بجولة في مركز الأعصاب هنا  في
مساحة لوكهيد مارتن في ليتلتون
كولورادو
ورائي مباشرة توجد منطقة دعم المهمة
أو MSA
وهذا هو المكان الذي يراقب فيه أعضاء فريق أوزيريس ريكس
المركبة الفضائية
الآن ،
لذا دعنا نرسلها إلى جاري ما
يجري على
جاري كما أوضحت لك  في وقت سابق ، كنا
قاب قوسين أو أدنى منك ، هذا هو
قلب عمليات العلامات
واعتقدنا أن هذا سيكون حقًا
وقتًا جيدًا للتسجيل مع
الفريق
لمعرفة كيف تسير الأمور  g وأفضل
شخص للقيام بذلك
هو الانضمام إلي وهذه صديقة ساندي ،
إنها مديرة عمليات Osiris-rex
هنا في Lockheed Martin ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لانضمامك إلينا ، كيف
حال الفريق ، الفريق رائع ، لقد كنا هنا في
لوحات المفاتيح منذ ذلك الحين  الساعة السادسة صباح هذا اليوم ، قم
بتعيين الأوامر النهائية للاستعداد
للعلامة
الرائعة حقًا ، وأعلم أن هناك ما يقرب من 40
شخصًا في فريق الرحلة الإجمالي الخاص بك ، ولكن
يبدو أن هناك حوالي 20 منهم
هنا الآن ، ربما نوعًا ما يعطينا فكرة صغيرة عن
من هم  من هؤلاء الأشخاص
وما يفعلونه ،
نعم بالتأكيد ، هذا هو فريق orex المذهل ،
يمكنك رؤية
جميع أنظمتنا الفرعية هنا على وحدة التحكم التي
تراقب القياس عن بُعد
كما ذكرت ، لا يمكننا أن نجعل
الجميع هنا لدينا العديد من
أعضاء الفريق الذين يدعمون  من غرف المؤتمرات الأخرى
في المبنى وبعضها حتى من
المنزل ،
لذا دعنا نتحدث عن اثنين من
المواضع التي لدينا في الغرفة في
الزاوية الخلفية هناك دايل هاويل
ديل هو قائد مرحلة العلامة لدينا
عند سماع صوته ينادي الأحداث أثناء
استكمالها
على متن المركبة الفضائية هنا في
المنطقة المركزية ، لدينا كورتيس ميلر
كورتيس ، وهو قائدنا السابق وهو يراقب
تتبع السمات
الطبيعية وهذه هي الطريقة التي ننتقل بها إلى
سطح بيني اليوم
لذا فهو يشاهد  كيف يقوم nft بأداء
عدد الميزات التي
نطابقها وكيف يعمل هذا النظام حتى أعرف أن
تتبع الميزات الطبيعية كما
تقول هو نوع من مراقبة
إخبارنا إلى أين نحن ذاهبون وأنا أعلم
أننا ذاهبون إلى  ادخل إلى ذلك
لاحقًا قليلاً في العرض ،
ولكن من المهم أيضًا أن تظل على
اتصال بالمركبة الفضائية ،
فماذا عن coms نعم تمامًا
ورائي هنا هي سييرا غونزاليس ، إنها
عاملنا الحقيقي أو
الآس هي تعمل مع أعماقنا
شركاء شبكة الفضاء
حاليًا في محطة في
جولدستون وفي
كانبيرا نتأكد من أننا نحافظ على رابطنا الهادئ
وأن
رابط com الخاص بنا هو 40 بت في الثانية
فقط ، لذا فنحن ننزل هذه المعلومات الأساسية فقط.
t sierra هنا
للتأكد من
استمرار هذا الارتباط وإبلاغ مشغلي المحطات لدينا
،
وبجوارها توجد
كنيسة estelle و estelle هي منسق الأنظمة لدينا
لهذا الحدث
، لقد قامت ببناء جميع منتجات الأوامر
التي يتم تنفيذها وهي
تراقب كيف يتم كل شيء  التقدم على متن
المركبة الفضائية بالتحدث إلى جميع أنظمتنا
الفرعية هنا في الغرفة
والتأكد من أن الأمور تسير كما هو
مخطط لها جيدًا جدًا ، وأعلم أنك كنت في
الواقع في هذا
المشروع منذ فترة طويلة لقد
عدنا إلى التطوير كيف حالك  أشعر
الليلة
أنني لست متحمسًا في الواقع ، أشعر وكأننا
فعلنا كل ما في وسعنا
لإنجاح هذا الأمر
، ولقد كنت في هذه المهمة لمدة سبع
سنوات ، لذلك شاهدتها تنتقل من
مركبتنا الفضائية على الورق إلى بنائها
خليجنا المرتفع
للإطلاق وكل شيء هنا ، نعم
أنا متحمس كان أطفالي متحمسين هذا
الصباح ونحن جاهزون تمامًا لهذا
الأمر رائع لذا سنسمح لكم
يا رفاق بالعودة إليه وأنا أعلم
أننا لا نفعل ذلك  أريد مقاطعة ساندي كثيرًا ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك على انضمامك
إلينا وأنا أعلم أن الناس في جميع أنحاء العالم
يهتمون بهذا الأمر في الوقت الحالي ،
فنحن نشهد وصول عدد كبير من وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ،
لذا دعنا ننتقل إلى جيمس على
مكتب وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي  ونرى ما الذي تدور حوله بعض هذه
المحادثات حول
نعم ، شكرًا غاري ، إنه لأمر رائع أن ترى
الفريق هناك في MSA ، يمكنك
حقًا أن تشعر بالطاقة في الغرفة
خاصة بعد كل مكالمة من
دايل وحقًا إلى موقف
العلامة الثالث والأخير  سلوك تتبع الميزات الطبيعية على
ما يرام ، لذلك نحن
نقترب شيئًا فشيئًا من سطح bennu
ولكننا نريد اليوم أيضًا أن نسمع
منك حتى تتمكن من التحقق من
التحديثات الحية على حساب
Twitter الخاص بنا على osiris-rex أو استخدام علامة التصنيف هذه
benewin مرة أخرى عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي للدخول
في المحادثة
في هذه الأثناء ، كان لدي سؤال
عندما بدأت في تغطية المهمة لأول مرة هو
كيف يمكنك حتى البدء في الاستعداد
لمهمة هذه المهارة ، أعني عندما
أتلقى أول سؤال  rd حول Osiris-rex ، بدا الأمر حقًا
وكأنه شيء من فيلم بميزانية كبيرة ،
لكن هذه حقيقة
سنحاول فعلاً أخذ عينات منها على كويكب
لوضع الأمور في نصابها بالنسبة لك ، فإن
بينو يقارب حجم
دولة الإمبراطورية  مبنى
صغير حقًا لجسم ما ويجعل من
الصعب للغاية بالنسبة لنا أن
ندور حول شيء به مجال جاذبية ضعيف
وهذا الموقع النموذجي الذي نذهب إليه
اليوم
يبلغ عرضه بضعة أمتار فقط وهو
بحجم عدد قليل من مواقف السيارات
لذلك خذ خطوة للوراء لثانية واحدة
وضع نفسك في مكان بعض
هؤلاء المهندسين في هذه المهمة
وتخيل أنك تحاول إيقاف مركبة فضائية
على كويكب على بعد
200 مليون ميل في مساحة لا
تزيد عن عدد قليل من أماكن وقوف السيارات
كما لو  وقوف السيارات بشكل متوازي على كويكب
ليس بالأمر الصعب ،
تخيل أيضًا محاولة تفادي المخاطر
مثل الصخور الصخرية
وجميع أنواع الأشياء أثناء
قيامك بالنزول لجمع عينة
وفوق ذلك الفريق  لقد
برمجت المركبة الفضائية بالفعل لتوجيه
نفسها إلى السطح
، إنها حقًا مهمتها
مذهلة وكل البصيرة التي دخلت
فيها أذهلتني حقًا ،
لدينا في الواقع سؤالان
قادمان من تويتر ويسأل الكثير من
الناس عن  استخدامنا
للوقود للمهمة ،
هذا السؤال الوحيد هو السؤال عن كيفية حصول
المركبة على وقود كافٍ للعودة إلى
الأرض
من الكويكب ، لذلك نحن نتطلع إلى
إعادة تلك العينة في عام 2023
وأوزوريس ريكس هي الدافعات التي تعمل بالفعل
بواسطة الهيدرازين  يتم تخزينه
في حاوية على المركبة الفضائية ،
فنحن نستغل القليل من هذا
الوقود اليوم بترتيب ربما عشرات
الجرامات ليس كثيرًا
لأن بينو ، كما تتذكر ، لديه
بيئة الجاذبية الصغرى هذه
ويتطلب القليل من الدفع إلى
اركلنا في الاتجاه الصحيح لجمع عينة
من رحلة العودة إلى الأرض هذه
قصة مختلفة بعض الشيء ، سنستخدم
الكثير من الوقود لذلك
ولكن لا تقلق  لقد فكر الفريق في
المضي قدمًا وقام بتعبئة أكثر من
وقود كافٍ لإعادتنا إلى هنا بأمان في عام 2023
ولكن هناك المزيد في المستقبل
وسأعود معك بعد دقيقة واحدة
فقط إليك ميشيل
شكرًا لك جيمس حسنًا ،  دعنا نلقي
نظرة سريعة على المحاكاة لنرى
أين
نحن كما لاحظت مع المحاكاة
، فقد
امتدت ذراع المركبة الفضائية الآن وهي على مسار بطيء
نحو السطح
حتى نقترب من لحظة
الاتصال ، تبدأ الدراما بالحدوث  بالحركة
البطيئة وهذا لزيادة الدقة
وتقليل المفاجآت غير المقصودة ،
لذا عند الحديث عن المفاجآت ، هناك جانب واحد
كبير من مهمة أوزيريس ريكس
يتعلق بالتحضير لما هو غير متوقع
والانضمام إلينا لمناقشة هذا الأمر هو
مدير قسم علوم الكواكب في ناسا
لوري جليز  الآن لورا لديك نوع من
التخصص الدرامي
والمسؤولية التي تأتي مع
منصبك في ناسا ، أنت قلق بالفعل
بشأن أشياء مثل حماية
الكواكب أو حماية الكواكب أو جيش التحرير الشعبى الصينى  netary يدافع
عن كوكبنا من التأثيرات المحتملة و
bennu في فئة خاصة وأعتقد أن
dante تحدث عن هذا قبل ذلك بقليل
أن uh
bennu هو في الواقع كائن قريب من الأرض أو
neo um والجسم الجديد أو القريب من الأرض هو
كويكب أو
مذنب يدور حول الشمس مثلما
تفعل كواكبنا ، لكنه غير معتاد إلى
حد ما ، لقد وصل أولريش أوبريكس إلى الموقف الطبيعي الثالث والأخير
لتتبع السمة الطبيعية
، حيث ستحافظ المركبة الفضائية على هذا الموقف الثابت
حتى يتم وضع علامة على
الأخبار الرائعة الرائعة ، لذا نعود إلى نيوس ،
لذا فإن نيو نوعا ما  غير عادي من حيث
أن مداراتهم تجعلهم
بالقرب من مدار الأرض ،
فإن التعريف الفني لـ neo هو
شيء يقع على بعد حوالي 30
مليون ميل
من مدار الأرض والكويكبات
تقترب فعليًا من الأرض
طوال الوقت يمر واحد أو اثنان في الأسبوع في
الواقع
بين الأرض والقمر ، لكن
معظمها صغير جدًا وليس خطيرًا ،
لكن الكويكبات ذات الحجم الأكبر بكثير
يمكن أن تلحق الضرر بالفعل بكوكب الأرض.
إذا كانت ستتأثر
، فيمكنها المرور بالأرض بالقرب من
القمر مرة واحدة
شهريًا تقريبًا ولهذا السبب من المهم حقًا بالنسبة
لنا العثور عليها في
أقرب وقت ممكن حتى نتمكن من تتبع
مداراتها
ودراسة خصائصها وإذا
لزم الأمر يمكننا التخفيف
من  تهديد تأثير محتمل في المستقبل
وهذا هو المكان
الذي تُسمى فيه المهمة التي نبنيها الآن
اختبار إعادة توجيه الكويكب المزدوج
، حيث يأتي دور السهام وسيبدأ السهام في
الصيف المقبل 2021 وسيختبر
شيئًا
نسميه تقنية التصادم الحركي التي
يمكنها  يمكن استخدامها يومًا ما لمساعدتنا في
التخفيف من خطر الاصطدام المحتمل في المستقبل
عن طريق اصطدام كويكب بطيء
على الإطلاق في مسار متقارب مع
كوكبنا في مدار مختلف قليلاً ،
لذا فهو يفتقد إلى الأرض
قليلاً فقط هو كل ما
تحتاجه  قليلًا ،
لذلك أعني أن هذا مثير حقًا الآن ، فأنا
أفهم أيضًا أنه ليست كل
الكويكبات في النظام الشمسي
متشابهة ،
فهناك أنواع مختلفة وناسا  لديه
بعض المهام القادمة لدراسة
هذه الأنواع المختلفة من الكويكبات ، لذا
أخبرنا قليلاً عن ذلك من فضلك ،
نعم ، نحن نعلم أن
غالبية كويكباتنا موجودة
في حزام الكويكبات الرئيسي بين المريخ
والمشتري وفي الحقيقة لدينا مهمة
مستمرة  سيتم إطلاقه في عام 2022
، وهو يسمى psyche ، وسوف يزور
أحد أكبر
الكويكبات في حزام الكويكبات والذي
يُطلق عليه في الواقع 16 نفسية
وستصل هذه المهمة في
أوائل عام
2026 وتساعدنا على فهم أفضل لما إذا كان هذا
الكويكب هو في
الواقع جوهر  جسم بحجم الكوكب ،
لدينا أيضًا أنواع أخرى من الكويكبات
تسمى أحصنة طروادة
والتي تتجمع في مجموعتين تقودان
وتتبعهما في مدار كوكب المشتري بسبب موازنة
سحب كل من جاذبية المشتري والشمس
عليها.
كويكبات طروادة تسمى لوسي ،
وسوف يتم إطلاقها
في العام المقبل في الخريف المقبل بعد حوالي عام من
الآن ، وسوف تقوم بزيارة العديد
من كويكبات طروادة هذه.
لقد قمنا بمهمة جديدة تسمى جانوس
وقمنا باختيار هذه المهمة من خلال
خط برنامج المهمات الصغيرة البسيط ،
سترسل هذه المهمة في الواقع
مركبتين
فضائيتين صغيرتين صغيرتين جدًا إلى نظامين ثنائيين من
الكويكبات
وتساعدنا على فهم ما
يجعل أنظمة الكويكبات الثنائية هذه
مختلفة  من بعضنا البعض
، وبالتالي فإن دراسة هذا النطاق الكامل
لهذه العوالم الصغيرة المتنوعة ستستمر
في
مساعدتنا على سد الفجوات المعرفية حول كيفية
تشكل نظامنا الشمسي وتطوره
بمرور الوقت ،
لذا يبدو أنه مع كل هذه المهمات
القادمة نحن نوعًا ما في  عصر ذهبي
لاستكشاف الكويكبات ،
ولكن بعد ذلك هناك هذا الجانب الآخر من
مهمة أوزيريس-ريكس وهو
عينة
العودة واتضح أننا أيضًا
بدأنا هذا العصر الذهبي
للعودة والعودة إليها وليس فقط إلى الكويكبات.
صحيح ونحن
متحمسون حقًا لكل هذه العينات لأنها
ثمينة جدًا وهناك الكثير من العلوم التي
يمكننا القيام بها معهم بالإضافة إلى
نظام التشغيل  iris-rex ،
نحن أيضًا نتشارك مع
وكالة الفضاء اليابانية في مهمتهم المسماة
hayabusa ii
والتي هي بالفعل في طريقها
للعودة بجلب عينة من
ryugu سيعودون إلى الأرض
في ديسمبر ونحن أيضًا
نتشارك معها  وكالة الفضاء اليابانية في
مهمة أخرى من مهمتهم
والتي ستعيد عينة
من فوبوس وهو أحد قمري
المريخ ، ثم أخيرًا في نهاية
هذا العقد
سنرسل مهمة إلى المريخ
لاستعادة العينات
التي  تم جمعها بواسطة
المركبة الجوالة المثابرة التي تعد
حقًا أول مهمتنا في علم الأحياء الفلكية
من
ناسا وهي تركز على البحث عن
حياة محتملة للحياة القديمة
على سطح المريخ ، لذا فإن عينة العودة مهمة حقًا
لأنها تسمح لنا بدراسة هذه
العينات الأصلية هنا على الأرض
يمكننا ذلك  ثم استفد من
مختبراتنا بحجم الغرفة ،
كل هذا orex بدأ في نقل
المصفوفات الشمسية إلى تكوين y-wing
لتجنب الاتصال المحتمل
بالسطح أثناء  ضع علامة على الأخبار الرائعة ،
لذا عندما
نعيد العينات ،
يتيح لنا ذلك استخدام جميع
القدرات المختبرية الموجودة لدينا
هنا على الأرض ، يمكننا استخدام المجموعة الكاملة
من الأدوات العلمية التي
لدينا تحت
تصرفنا لمساعدتنا على فهم أفضل  تسمح لنا عينة
مكوناتها
وتاريخ الجسم الذي أتوا منه
وكذلك الحصول على العينات هنا
على الأرض بالحفاظ عليها
للأجيال القادمة
وتسمح للمستكشفين المستقبليين
بتحليل العينات
باستخدام تقنيات وأدوات
لم تفعل ذلك.  تم اختراعه
وطرح أسئلة لا نعرف حتى أن نسألها ،
فهذا رائع جدًا ، أعني أن
حياتك تدور حول كيفية التنقل بين المجهول ،
وهذا شيء يحدث في الوقت الفعلي من
حولنا الليلة ،
لذا من المطمئن معرفة أن هناك
خطة منظمة تكون
مسؤولاً عنها للمساعدة في إزالة بعض
أوجه عدم اليقين من فئة درامية واحدة على الأقل ،
لذا نشكرك لوري جليز على انضمامك إلينا
هذا  مساء الخير لرؤيتك ، شكرًا
جزيلاً لك على استضافتي ، أريد فقط أن
أضيف أنه كان من
الرائع مشاهدة مهمة Osiris-
rex حتى الآن وأنا متحمس حقًا
لما ينتظرنا الليلة وأريد
أن أتقدم بالتهنئة إلى
شكرًا جزيلاً لك ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك ، الآن
، لا يمكن التنقل بسهولة في الكويكبات ، ومن
الصعب أن نرى أنها تحتوي على
حقول جاذبية منخفضة ، فهي مظلمة وصخرية
، وتنتقل حول النظام الشمسي
حيث نادرًا ما يتحرك كل شيء
يعني السفر في خط مستقيم ،
دعنا  ألقِ نظرة على بعض التحديات
الكبيرة التي
تواجهها الفرق للوصول إلى هذه
النقطة
حيث بدأنا في الاقتراب من بينو من
مسافة وبدأنا في ملء
مجال رؤية الكاميرا ، بدا الأمر تمامًا
كما كنا نظن أنه سيكون مع بعض
الصخور الملتصقة  في الخارج ولكن مع اقترابنا ،
توقعنا أن نرى سطحًا رمليًا للغاية
مع ربما بعض الصخور هنا وهناك
وما رأيناه هو رمال صغيرة جدًا
ورأينا هذه الجبال رأينا
الصخور رأينا صخورًا
ورأيناها  بعض المناطق التي كان بها
هذا السطح الرملي الذي كنا
نتوقعه وما
صممناه لم نفعل ذلك أبدًا قبل
أن نجمع
عينة ونعيدها إلى الأرض
لمزيد من الفحص من قبل العلماء
من أجل تحقيق هذا الهدف  كانت
المركبة الفضائية أوزيريس-ريكس
تتنقل حول بينو منذ حوالي
العامين الماضيين
لدراستها بتفاصيل كبيرة وأيضًا
التغلب على عدد من التحديات
التي قدمها بينو ، كنا نبحث
عن مواقع في مكان
يبلغ قطرها 50 مترًا
مسطحة نسبيًا ومغطاة
المواد ذات الحبيبات الدقيقة والمواد ذات الحبيبات الدقيقة ،
أعني أشياء
بحجم عشرة سنتات أو أصغر ،
أدركنا أنه لا توجد مواقع في
بينو اقتربت حتى من تلبية
هذه المعايير في
كل مكان نظرنا إليه كانت صغيرة جدًا
ومغطاة بالصخور
اضطررنا إلى التحليق بعدد من
التمريرات القريبة الإضافية فوق
الكويكب
وإعادة التفكير في خطتنا بأكملها للاستيلاء
على العينة
بعد المراقبة الإضافية  ns of
bennu اضطررنا إلى التحديد إلى أربعة
مواقع
ثم العودة ومسح تلك المواقع
إلى أبعد من ذلك لتحديد موقع العينة الأولية النهائي ، وكان
انطباعي الأول عن العندليب هو
المكان الأخير الذي أردت الذهاب إليه
ولكن عندما بدأنا في البحث عن مواقع أخرى
لقد رأينا أن هذا أحد المواقع ربما يكون
أحد أكثر المواقع التي يمكن أخذ عينات منها ، واثنان
كنا نفرط في الأداء في قدرتنا على
التنقل وقدرتنا على
الاتصال
بتتبع الميزات الطبيعية يعمل كثيرًا
مثل العقل البشري من حيث أننا نلتقط
المعالم على طول الطريق
أثناء نزولنا  نحن ننظر إلى الميزات الموجودة على
الأرض ، ونقوم ببرمجة الكمبيوتر
للتعرف على ميزات معينة ، حيث يلتقط
صورة
تقول إن هذه الميزة ليست في المكان الذي كنت
أتوقع أن تكون فيه ، إنها متوقفة قليلاً
إلى الجانب ، يتم
تحديث موضعه بناءً على المكان الذي
يشير إليه وأين هذه الميزة  يظهر
في موضع الكاميرا
، حدث العلامة هو حدث اللمس
والانطلاق ، حيث سنسترجع العينة من asteroid bennu ، نبدأ بسلسلة من
المناورة  rs إحداها هي
نقطة التفتيش المحترقة ، حيث سنقوم
بالفعل بفحص سرعة موضعنا
بالنسبة
لمواقع العينة ثم تحترق نقطة المطابقة بعد
حوالي 10 دقائق
سنخرج سرعتنا الأفقية
بالنسبة للسطح
ثم حوالي  بعد 10 دقائق ،
قمنا بالاتصال بالعلامة
سام
، أطلقنا زجاجة الغاز ثم تراجعنا ونأمل أن نحصل
على 60 جرامًا على الأقل من العينة ومن ثم
سنتمكن من تخزين
ذلك وإعادته إلى الأرض ولكن
هناك  العديد من الأشياء التي يمكن أن
تسوء وعلينا أيضًا أن نكون
مستعدين لأننا لن ننجح في محاولتنا الأولى
في العندليب ، فنحن لا نحصل على طلقة واحدة فقط
في العلامة ،
فلدينا بالفعل ثلاث زجاجات نيتروجين
على متن المركبة الفضائية حتى نتمكن من ذلك
قم
بثلاث محاولات لوضع العلامات إذا لزم الأمر ،
نمر بالعديد
من سيناريوهات ماذا لو وهذه هي الطريقة التي
نستعد بها بالفعل للعديد من
حالات الطوارئ الخاصة بنا ،
لذلك كان علينا أن ننظر في جميع أنحاء
السطح ونحدد
الصخور والصخور التي إذا كانت
الفضاء  كان من المقرر أن تنقلب ecraft بما يصل إلى 25
درجة ،
فقد تلامسها وتتلف ،
وكان علينا تطوير خريطة للمخاطر
نقوم ببرمجتها في الكمبيوتر ونقول
إذا كنت تقترب جدًا من تلك
المخاطر ، فسنقوم بإيقافنا
سنعود بعيدًا عن الكويكب
سنعود ونفعل هذا في يوم آخر ،
قد يعمل كل شيء بشكل مثالي ،
فنحن نلمس السطح حيث
نريد إطلاق زجاجة الغاز ، لكن المنطقة التي نتصل
بها مغطاة بصخور كبيرة تلك الصخور
من شأنه أن يمنع أي مادة حبيبية دقيقة
من التقليب والتقاطها في
رأس علامة سام
سيناريو آخر مشابه هو إذا كانت
علامة سام تلمس حافة
صخرة وتصبح مائلة
في هذه الحالة عندما تطلق زجاجة الغاز
الكثير من هذا الغاز  يفلت من الجانب
لا يخلط المواد التي
نريد التقاطها في يوم العلامة
سيكون أمرًا مثيرًا حقًا لكن الإثارة
لفريقنا لا تنتهي عند هذا الحد ،
علينا التحقق من أن لدينا عينة مناسبة
أولاً نحن ذاهبون  لتصوير ملف  ضع علامة على رأس سام من
خلال الالتصاق أمام إحدى
الكاميرات ، ثم سنقوم
بمناورة تسمى قياس كتلة العينة
حيث نخرج
الذراع ونقوم بتدوير المركبة
الفضائية حتى نقرر ما إذا كنا قد
جمعنا ما يكفي  الكتلة لتتمكن من
تخزين العينة
والعودة إلى المنزل أو إذا كان علينا المحاولة
مرة أخرى ، فهذا تتويج لكثير
من العمل ، فمن المحتمل أن تكون إحدى أكثر
المهام إثارة التي عملت عليها ،
ومن المثير حقًا معرفة أننا "
ستتمكن أخيرًا من
لمس سطح الكويكب
وجمع العينة للعودة إلى
الأرض ،
لذا تراجع للحظة وأدرك
أن أحداث الليلة نادرة للغاية
وأن
البشرية التاريخية لم تهبط إلا على عدد قليل من
الأجسام المختلفة في الشمس  النظام
واستعادة العينة
أكثر ندرة ،
لحسن الحظ معي الليلة ، هناك
بعض الأشخاص الذين يعرفون أفضل من أي شخص
جميع التحديات التي استغرقها الأمر للوصول إلى
هنا ، لذا دعني أقدم مايك موريو
مايك هو قسم أوزوريس ريكس
مدير مشروع في مركز جودارد لرحلات
الفضاء وكورالي آدم
هو مدير ملاحة العلامات في شركة كينيتكس إيروسبيس ،
لذا نرحب بمايك
وكورالي.  لذلك يجب أن أذكر في هذه
المرحلة أنه من المحتمل أنك
سمعت هذا قبل هتافات من وكالة الفضاء الأوروبية ،
لذا هل يمكنك أن تعطينا فكرة عما
يحدث الآن ، نعم ، كل بضع دقائق
، يتم التقاط صورة لكاميرا الملاحة بواسطة
المركبة الفضائية الموجودة على السطح  أدناه
ويتم إرساله إلى
نظام تتبع الميزة الطبيعية وهذا النظام
يحدد الميزات في الصورة
ويرسل إشارة إلى الأرض
، كان عدم اليقين الناجح
0.5 متر ويحتفل الفريق
بذلك يخبرنا أننا على الطريق الصحيح نحو هدفنا التالي
وعلى  تتبع للوسم ،
لذا من الواضح الآن أن هناك الكثير
مما يمكن الحديث عنه فيما يتعلق بالمهمة ،
ولكن مرة أخرى كان عليك أن تفعل كل هذا
في خضم هذا الوباء الـ19 ،
لذا كان هناك أي مهمة  التوقعات
التي غيرت
كيف تعاملت مع هذا نعم بالتأكيد ،
أعني أن العالم كله كان يقترب من
السيطرة على الوباء في الإطار الزمني لمسيرة
كان هذا الفريق في خضم التحضير
لأول تدريب على العلامة
أه تمرين نقطة التفتيش التي
ستستغرق  المركبة الفضائية على ارتفاع 65 مترًا فقط
فوق السطح ، لذلك كان علينا إعادة التفكير
في الطريقة الكاملة التي كنا سنفعل بها
تلك البروفة
مع طاقم هيكل عظمي فقط هنا في
المبنى ومع العديد من
أعضاء فريقنا بعيدًا كما ذكر ساندي قبل
اليوم.  حرفيًا في جميع
أنحاء المبنى ، يتم أيضًا مراقبة جميع أنحاء المبنى في
مركز جودارد لرحلات الفضاء وفي
جامعة أريزونا
لمشاهدة هذا الحدث اليوم ، ولكن لحسن
الحظ أجرينا بروفة عند نقطة التفتيش في
أبريل ونقطة المباراة في
أغسطس وجميع الاعتبارات الخاصة
التي لا يزالون يدورون حولنا  اليوم ،
نعم ، أعني أنه كان بإمكانك رؤية أشخاص
متباعدة في MSA عندما تكون
هناك وأنت تعلم أنه كان لدينا المزيد من الوقت
للاستعداد  من
أجل استيعاب ذلك وإدخال
الجميع إلى المبنى هنا اليوم ، لذا
فأنا فخور للغاية بفريقنا ،
لأنك تعرف جهودهم
لإبقاء المشروع على المسار الصحيح على الرغم من
كل هذه التحديات
تمامًا لذا فأنا أعرف ناسا.
مشهور بضرورة التعامل مع مواقف غير متوقعة
وهذا الشيء الـ19 هو
نوع من نكهة مختلفة للمواقف غير المتوقعة
التي سنتعامل معها ،
لذلك دعونا الآن نتحدث أكثر عن
تحديات العلامة التي قدمناها في
مقطع الفيديو حتى ربع سنوي
حسنًا ، لقد رأيت أن
موقع العندليب هو
مكان صعب للغاية للتنقل إلى
هناك
صخور في كل مكان حوله ، وهذا
مختلف تمامًا عن الطريقة التي
صممنا بها النظام
في الأصل لاستهداف منطقة يبلغ قطرها 50 مترًا
أصغر بعشر مرات من ذلك
تطلب الأمر من الفريق بأكمله إعادة التفكير في كيفية
التنقل بأمان
في هذا التلامس مع السطح
والأم ، وكان علينا أن نخرج ببعض الأفكار الجديدة ،
نعم  استخدم نهج الملاحة
نظام الملاحة القائم على الليدار أو الليزر لنقلنا إلى
فوهة العندليب ، ولكن عندما رأينا كيف
بدا بينو ، أدركنا أنه يتعين علينا
التبديل إلى نهج قائم على الرؤية
وهذا هو نظام nft الذي كنت
تسمعه عنه
،  قضى فريق الملاحة الحركية
العامين الماضيين
أه يتعلم كيفية التنقل حول بينو
باستخدام تقنيات الملاحة الضوئية
أه مشابه جدًا لما تفعله Nft على
متن المركبة الفضائية اليوم ،
لذا عملت الحركية مع العلماء
وعالجت شركة lockheed martin
nfts rex موقعها التالي في
الصورة  عدم اليقين
هو 0.5 متر ،
لذلك قمنا بتعيين سطح المكان
بدقة غير مسبوقة تبلغ 2
سم لكل بكسل
وهو أفضل مما فعلناه
على الأرض والقمر لدينا ،
لذلك كان جهدًا هائلاً للغاية
للوصول إلى هذه النقطة حيث نحن
مريح عند
تسليم الخرائط والمفاتيح إلى
المركبة الفضائية لإيصالنا إلى هذا
الموقع الصغير اليوم تمامًا لذا أعتقد
أنه حان الوقت الآن لنقول وداعًا
يا رفاق ، حظًا سعيدًا لهذا اليوم ،
أنا متحمس حقًا ومن الرائع
أن أكون معكم يا رفاق ،
شكرًا لك ميشيل ، حسنًا ،
الآن أعتقد أن أفضل
شيء يمكن فعله هو تسجيل الوصول مع غاري نابيير.
أعتقد أننا سنعود
ونرى كيف ستعود الأمور إلى هناك ،
لذا فإن الأمور تسير على ما يرام حقًا
الآن ميشيل ،
سنتحدث بالفعل إلى هيذر
إينوس هنا
الممثل المشارك على سبيل المثال
جامعة أريزونا شكرًا على  الانضمام
إلينا هيذر
هاي غاري ، لذا فإن الشيء المثير للاهتمام حقًا
هيذر هو أنك تشعر في الواقع
أنك تعرف أن المهمات الطويلة مثل هذه
مهمة حقًا ، أعني
أنك تنتقل من التصميم إلى البناء ولكن
العمليات حقًا تستغرق وقتًا طويلاً ومن
المهم حقًا
إشراك ذلك بعد ذلك  جيل ونوع من
إحضار هذا الجيل ،
تحدث إلينا قليلاً عن هذا الأمر
تمامًا ، فأنت محق
تمامًا منذ أن بدأنا في
التخطيط لهذه المهمة من سايروس ريكس ، لقد أدركنا
ذلك "  مهمة طويلة الأمد وعلى
الرغم من أن ذلك
يمثل تحديات للاحتفاظ
بموظفيك الرئيسيين ، فقد انتهزناها بالفعل كفرصة
لاستخدام هذه المهمة لتدريب
الجيل القادم من الطلاب
أه ومهندسي العلوم
والعلماء خير مثال على ذلك هو أنه كان لدينا أه أحد
علومنا أه
تسمى الأدوات rexus ، إنها
مطياف الأشعة السينية التي صممها فريق من
الطلاب في معهد ماساتشوستس للتكنولوجيا وجامعة هارفارد ،
لذا فإن التدريب العملي الحقيقي أمر
مثير للاهتمام حقًا أعني أنني أفهم أن لديك أيضًا
بعض
الأشخاص الذين كانوا في الواقع طلابًا
وانضموا إلى الفريق لاحقًا ،
نعم.  في جامعة
أريزونا في مهمة بقيادة بي
أه كان لدينا المئات من طلاب البكالوريوس
والدراسات العليا الذين يعملون في هذه
المهمة
على مدار العقد الماضي
واثنين
من طلابنا الذين يبدأون مع
الطلاب هما في الواقع اثنان من
أعضاء فريق الملاحة لدينا  هذا هو دان
ويتمان وإيريك سارك ، واو ،
إنهما على وحدة التحكم ، إنهما موجودان الآن ،
نعم ،
لقد قام nfc بحساب
نقطة التفتيش  وتحديثات حرق نقطة المطابقة
لتصحيح الأخطاء في المسار
المتراكم منذ
احتراق نقطة تفتيش انطلاق المدار في دقيقتين ، لذا
استدر نقطة التفتيش في دقيقتين ، سنقوم
برميها مرة أخرى إلى أه ميشيل
لأنني أعرف أن هذا
تحديث مهم لها  لذا ،
شكرًا ميشيل مرة أخرى ، شكرًا
لك ، شكرًا غاري
تمامًا ، أخبرنا dante ما الذي
تعنيه نقطة التفتيش المهمة هذه أن هذا
جزء مهم حقًا من المهمة في
الوقت الحالي ، لذا فقد سمعنا عن
تتبع الميزات الطبيعية وكيفية
معالجتها لهذه الصور  لقد عالجت msa على rx
ops orex
عدم التيقن من موضع الصورة التالي
وهو 0.46 مترًا على اليمين ، لذا فإن ما
تفعله بهذه المعلومات هو
أنها تحسب أه كيف ستطلق محركاتها
لنقطة التفتيش هذه
عندما غادرنا المدار كنا في
مسار من شأنه أن يأخذنا
فوق سطح الكويكب ، وإذا
لم يحدث شيء آخر ، فسنحلق بأمان
عبر بينو
بمجرد إطلاق الدفاعات
لرجل الحاجز  في
الواقع ، سنبدأ في النزول
لأسفل باتجاه سطح الكويكب ،
وهذا يعني أننا سنكون في طريقنا
لإجراء اتصال ، لذا فإن تتبع الميزات الطبيعية
لم يفعل شيئًا سوى
حساب هذه المناورة
منذ أن بدأنا في التقاط الصور ، لذلك هذا
هو  واحدة من الصفقات الكبيرة ، هذه واحدة
من المعالم الكبيرة القادمة ، هذا
ضخم ،
نعم بالتأكيد أعلم أنه عندما ننظر
إلى المحاكاة ، هناك تكوين مثير للاهتمام ،
فإن المركبة الفضائية ليست كذلك ،
أرى أن الدافعات تطلق ، وهذا صحيح
يمكنك رؤيتنا  نتوقع الآن على
متن المركبة الفضائية أن
تطلق محركات الدفع ، لذا سنولي اهتمامًا وثيقًا
لدايل
هويل لإعلامنا بأننا استعدنا القياس عن بُعد
لإخبارنا أن المناورة
نجحت
في الوقت الحالي إذا كنت تريد أن تخبرنا  نحن
قليلاً عن التكوين ، إنه قيد
التنفيذ ، نعم سمعنا دايل ينادي في
وقت سابق أن المركبة الفضائية كانت في
تكوين y-wing هناك ، لقد أعدنا
تكوين المصفوفات الشمسية لإخراجها
بعيدًا  من سطح الكويكب بشكل أساسي
لحماية مناطقهم النشطة من أي
تحميل
غبار قد يتم تشغيله أثناء حدث العلامة ،
إنه مرجع ممتاز آخر لحروب النجوم
وهذا صحيح
يمكنك أيضًا رؤيته هنا في محاكاة
موقع عينة العندليب
الآن في الزاوية السفلية هنا
هذا هو هدفنا ، وهذا ما
نحاول الدخول إليه بهذه المركبة الفضائية
، لذا يبدو أن هناك الكثير من
الصخور حول ذلك ، كما قلنا
عمومًا ، سطح البينو
خشن وعرة ومغطى بالصخور
العندليب حقًا  تبرز
كمنطقة مثيرة للاهتمام وفريدة من نوعها على
السطح ،
كيف تقوم بعمل جيد مع
إيلاء اهتمام وثيق لذلك النداء ،
انتظر دايل ليخبرنا أن نقطة التفتيش قد
حدثت
تمامًا ، فما
ننتظره الآن هو استدعاء  لقد حدثت نقطة تفتيش
وبدأت المركبة الفضائية أوزيريس ريكس
في الهبوط
نحو سطح الكويكب في أي
وقت الآن
وربما يجدر ذكر
الفصل  لقد اكتمل حرق eckpoint ،
حسنًا ، نحن نتجه لأسفل نحو
سطح الكويكب في هذه المرحلة ،
أوه ،
رائع ، حسنًا ، أنت تعلم جيدًا ، أعتقد
أن الشيء التالي الذي سيظهر هو أه
ستكون مناورة نقطة المباراة هذه بحيث تكون
هذه الخطوة الكبيرة التالية  علامة فارقة بالنسبة لنا ، هذا
صحيح ، لذا فقد حصلنا على إطلاق واحد آخر
من الدافعات بالمركبة الفضائية
لجعلنا نصطف
لحدث اقتناء العينة الذي نسميه نقطة المطابقة ،
لأن ما نقوم به هناك
حاليًا أثناء تحليقنا فوق
سطح الكويكب في الواقع هو
سطح الكويكب الذي يدور
تحته وعندما نطلق محركات الدفع لنقطة المطابقة ،
فإننا نفعل ذلك لمطابقة
سرعة الدوران
بحيث تصبح المركبة الفضائية محطة
تحافظ بشكل أساسي على موقع عينة العندليب هذا على ما
يرام تمامًا لذا أعتقد أننا
لديك القليل من الوقت الآن للتوجه إلى
مكتب وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الخاص بنا ، لذا آه جيمس ما الذي
يحدث على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
نعم ميشيل إنه لأمر مثير للغاية
أنك سمعت للتو تأكيد حرق نقطة التفتيش
نحن الآن
قريبون جدًا جدًا من سطح العندليب
وقد كنتم يا رفاق متحمسون حقًا
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي أيضًا مع هذا
الهاشتاغ لبينو وإرجاع
الكثير من الرسائل الرائعة التي تتداول هنا ،
شخص ما متحمس حقًا
لصديقنا الروبوت الصغير
للذهاب إلى موسيقى الروك  الصيد على السطح ،
كان لدينا شخص حضر
إطلاقنا مرة أخرى في غضون عامين مضت
، وهو الآن يشاهد البث المباشر
معنا اليوم متحمسًا لحدث جمع العينات
هذا ،
لدينا فيليب الذي يضعها في
منظورها الصحيح بالنسبة لنا هنا هو  يقول إن هذا أمر
مذهل وصعب للغاية
من نواح كثيرة ،
حيث إن ميل دوران مدار بينو إلى
ميكانيكا المدار لهذه المهمة الطويلة
أمر مذهل ، ولا
يمكنني إلا أن أتخيل عدد
عمليات محاكاة المدار التي تم إجراؤها هنا على الأرض ،
إنها حقًا مهمة مجنونة ولدينا أيضًا
أصدقاء الحيوانات
حيواناتنا الأليفة التي تشجعنا هنا وكذلك بينو قاسي من هذين
الحيوانات الأليفة لدينا هنا متحمسون حقًا لذلك
نحن الآن على بعد دقائق فقط  لقد اشتعلت
نقطة التطابق ،
ولهذا سأعيدها إليك ميشيل
حسنًا ، حسنًا ، فأنت تعلم قبل بضع دقائق فقط ،
كنت تقول إن
موقع الهبوط هذا هو نوع من منطقة فريدة من نوعها
على الكويكب ،
أخبرنا عن هذا الموقع ، نعم نحن
بذلنا قدرًا هائلاً من الجهد في
تحديد المنطقة على سطح هذا الكويكب
حيث أردنا الحصول على
عينة
منها وقمنا نوعًا ما بتقسيم تحليلنا
إلى أربع فئات مختلفة
أولاً كنا نبحث في إمكانية
التسليم وكان هذا
تحديًا حقيقيًا لأننا كما نحن  لقد رأينا
سابقًا في البث أن
دقة التوجيه الأصلية كانت نصف قطرها 25 مترًا
ونحاول الوصول إلى منطقة تبلغ
مساحتها 10 بالمائة من هذا الحجم ، وقد
حللنا هذه
المشكلة من خلال
حل تتبع الميزات
الطبيعية المذهل ، وكما سمعنا أن هذا  لقد نجحت
بالفعل وقد قامت بتحديث نقطة التفتيش
الخاصة بها ومناورات نقطة المطابقة على متنها
بناءً على تلك المعلومات
التي تنقلك إلى سطح
الكويكب ، لذا فإن الشيء التالي الذي لدينا
ما يدعو للقلق
هو الحفاظ على سلامة المركبات الفضائية ،
فهناك الكثير من المخاطر
على سطح هذا الكويكب والأشياء التي
يمكن أن تلحق الضرر بمكون مهم
، وقررنا تركيز السلامة على
الأشياء التي كانت مطلوبة
لإعادة العينة إلى الأرض ،
لذلك هناك أشياء معينة يمكننا القيام بها
يخسرون في هذه المرحلة من المهمة إذا
لم يحققوا هذا الهدف ،
فلا يزال لدينا بعض المعالم الرئيسية القادمة
التي تساعدنا في الحفاظ على
سلامة المركبات الفضائية
الآن ، حيث سيتحول تتبع الميزات الطبيعية
إلى حساب
نقطة الاتصال على سطح الكويكب.
لديه قطعة من البرنامج على متن الطائرة
تسمى خريطة المخاطر
التي تحددها فعليًا هي
الموقع الذي سأقوم
بلمسه في منطقة خضراء آمنة على
خريطة المخاطر هذه
أو أنه من المحتمل أن تكون منطقة حمراء
على خريطة المخاطر هذه خطرة
حتى نحصل عليها  بالقرب من سطح الكويكب ،
هناك لحظة رئيسية
هي العبور الذي يبلغ خمسة أمتار عندما
تتخذ المركبة الفضائية هذا القرار ،
هل أستمر في النزول لأجمع العينة
أو أفعل  لقد عدت
بعيدًا وأعيش لأضع علامة على يوم آخر
بعد أن نزلت إلى هناك ، فإن مركبتك الفضائية
آمنة ، يجب أن يكون هناك شيء يمكنك
التقاطه في وقت سابق في بيت البيرة العاشق الذي
أظهر لنا حجم الجسيمات التي
يمكن أن تجمعها علامة سام بالفعل
كان علينا رسم خريطة لمنطقة العندليب
ومواقع العينات المحتملة
الأخرى أقل بكثير من دقة السنتيمتر هذه
وفي الواقع حصلنا على
3.5 ملم لكل بكسل في
جميع أنحاء موقع عينة العندليب
وكنا متحمسين حقًا لرؤية
الكثير من الجسيمات بهذا الحجم
وبالطبع  كانت
المعلمة النهائية التي كنا نبحث عنها هي
القيمة
العلمية ويمكنني أن أخبرك أن الأخبار السارة هي أن أي
عينة من بينو ذات قيمة علمية
رأينا هذه المعادن الطينية الرطبة
التي رأيناها جزيئات عضوية تحمل معادن الكربون في
جميع أنحاء سطح  الكويكب هو
بالضبط نوع المادة التي
نأمل أن نحضرها إلى الوطن ،
لذلك أفهم أن المعلم الكبير التالي
الذي نبحث عنه هنا هو شيء
يسمى
نقطة المطابقة  هذا صحيح ، لذا فإن ما يحدث
عند نقطة المطابقة هو
المناورة الأخيرة التي تقوم بها المركبة الفضائية من
خلال إطلاق دافعاتها
وهذا هو المكان الذي نركز فيه
على
موقع عينة العندليب ونبدأ ذلك الهبوط النهائي
نزولاً إلى سطح الكويكب
وتكون المركبة الفضائية مركزة فقط  بناءً
على حساب الأمان
الخاص به والقرار بشأن
ما إذا كان سيتم المضي قدمًا في
جمع تلك العينة ،
كريس ، الشيء المذهل في
نقطة المطابقة هو أن الكويكب نفسه
يدور بالفعل ،
لذلك عندما نذهب إلى نقطة المطابقة ،
يجب أن تتطابق المركبة الفضائية مع دوران
الكويكب ، لذا فهو
ينزل مباشرة عليه وهذا صحيح ، لذا فإن
مدى السرعة التي يدور بها
المكان له فترة دوران تبلغ 4.3 ساعات ،
لذا فإن هذا هو أساسًا طول
اليوم
على كويكب على الأرض ، فإن
فترة الدوران هي 24 ساعة وهذا هو السبب في وجود يوم واحد
طولها على الأرض 24 ساعة ،
وهذا يترجم لأن بني
شيء صغير جدًا كما رأينا 500
متر أو حوالي نفس حجم
الإمبراطورية  مبنى الولاية
عند خط الاستواء ، يتحرك السطح بسرعة
10 سنتيمترات في الثانية
، وهو في الواقع يصبح أبطأ وأبطأ
كلما انتقلت إلى خطوط عرض أعلى
بحلول الوقت الذي تصل فيه إلى القطب الشمالي ،
يكون الصفر عند الشمال بعيدًا جدًا ،
لذا فهو في الواقع أقل بكثير من
10  سنتيمترات في
الثانية وهذا نوع من يظهر لك
الطبيعة الدقيقة الدقيقة
لهذه المهمة ، كما تعلم ، يجب أن
نحصل على مناورات دفع منخفضة
جدًا ، نهج دقيق للغاية بطيء جدًا
لسطح الكويكب ،
كل شيء يحدث في
حركة بطيئة أثناء التشغيل  في
بيئة الجاذبية الصغرى مثل بينو ،
إذن ما هو المعلم الهام التالي
بعد نقطة المباراة
آه بعد نقطة المباراة ، سنبحث عن
نظام تتبع الميزات الطبيعية الذي
يعود عبر الإنترنت مع التقاط تلك الصور
والارتباطات الإضافية والدقة في
معرفته بموقعه  وقد
نتوقع أن يقفز في الواقع لأننا
نسمع
خاصية تتبع الشكوك الطبيعية
في حدود نصف متر
قد يرتفع الأمر قليلاً مع
التعرف
على أن نظام تتبع الميزات الطبيعية لـ orex قد
استأنف معالجة
موضع عدم اليقين وهو 1.6 متر لذا
يمكنك أن ترى هناك عدنا إلى 1.6
متر وذلك لأننا مررنا
بمناورة نقطة التفتيش
لذلك كلما قمت بنقل مثل هذا الاتجاه
يضيف عدم اليقين إلى النظام
أه ونحن نرى أنه مع
نظام تتبع الميزات الطبيعية في الوقت
الحالي ،
هذا أمر مثير للغاية ، لذلك دعونا نقدم
المدير المساعد
لناسا دكتور توماس ، سيدي توماس ، شكرًا
لك على انضمامك إلينا.  سعيد لوجودي
معكم جميعًا ،
إنه وقت ممتع عيد ميلاد توماس السعيد ،
شكرًا ، هذا صحيح
بالأمس هو عيد ميلاده ،
نعم ، هذا عيد ميلاد سعيد صحيح ، لذا فأنت
تعلم أن
الجميع هنا يهدف إلى هذه
النقطة الزمنية التي تسمى أه أنت تعرف
هذا  tag sam ولكن اتضح أنه
كان هناك الكثير من الأصدقاء والكثير من
الزملاء الذين ساعدونا في الوصول إلى
هذه اللحظة
حتى تعرف من كان معنا  معنا في
هذه الرحلة ، انظر جيدًا ، أعني أن
هناك عددًا من الشركاء المحليين بالطبع ،
العديد منهم هنا
تتحدث إلى بعضهم ولكن هناك أيضًا
شركاء دوليون
ووكالة الفضاء الكندية قدمت
مقياس الارتفاع بالليزر الذي يعد أداة مهمة
هنا وفي  بالطبع
لدينا شراكة مع jaxa آه
ما سنفعله هو في الواقع
مشاركة عينات من
ryuko من hayabusa إلى آسف
threx معنا بمجرد عودته لأقصى قدر من
العلم وهذا حقًا ما تدور
حوله الشراكات الدولية لذلك هذا كبير
مهمة لناسا ولكن اتضح أن
هناك أنواعًا مختلفة من
الشركاء في مهمة مثل هذه
تعطينا إحساسًا بمجموعة الشركاء
الذين ننظر إليهم جيدًا ، أعني أنها تبدأ
من جامعة أريزونا
حيث توجد
القيادة ومعها  أنت هناك وفريقك بأكمله ،
لكن مركز رحلات الفضاء ناسا
جودارد هو شريك مهم في
الإدارة بالطبع ، وخاصة
العمل أيضًا مع لوكهيد مارتن الذي حقًا
أنت تعلم أن هذا الفريق يستحق الكثير
من الفضل والحركية التي تم تقديمها بالفعل
بالإضافة إلى العديد من الآخرين الذين تعرفهم إذا
كنت تبحث في كثير من الأحيان عن
مهمات كهذه تمس العديد من
الولايات في جميع أنحاء الولايات المتحدة
تمامًا ، لذا
أشكرك على انضمامك إلينا.  وسنراكم
لاحقًا في البرنامج ، كيف تشعر يا
رجل ،
أنا متحمس جدًا آه هذه هي النهاية
مثل
10 12 دقيقة هنا للاتصال ، أشعر أنني بحالة
جيدة حقًا الفريق في حالة معنوية عالية
كما تحدثت أنا وأنت في وقت سابق من هذا
الأسبوع  لقد فعلنا كل ما هو ممكن
لجعل هذا اليوم ناجحًا
تمامًا وأنت تعلم أن
عقلك موجود بالفعل وأن
المركبة الفضائية في طريقها بالفعل للخروج في
الوقت الفعلي ، هل يمكنك أن تتخيل
أنه من الجيد حقًا الإشارة إلى ما
حدث مع  لقد حدثت العلامة بالفعل ،
لقد تجاوزنا
وقت الضوء في اتجاه واحد لمدة 18 دقيقة ونصف الساعة
تمامًا.
أنا قادم وأنا أعلم
النقطة الحرجة في نقطة المباراة ،
لذا
عند أي نقطة سنعرف
أننا نعلم بالفعل أن لدينا عينة
وهذا سؤال رائع أه لسنا
متأكدين تمامًا مما سيحدث على
الفور
نحن  "سنعرف ما إذا كنا قد
اتصلنا بسطح الكويكب اليوم ،
فسنعرف ما إذا كانت زجاجة الغاز قد انطلقت
ونعلم أننا تراجعنا بأمان بعيدًا
عن الكويكب ،
لكن لدينا في الواقع الكثير من العمل للقيام به
خلال الأسبوع المقبل أو نحو
ذلك"  سنلقي نظرة على الصور التي
حصلنا عليها أثناء ملامسة
سطح الكويكب
ومن ثم سنذهب إلى
حملة تصوير مختلفة أه
أه نحن على بعد حوالي 30 ثانية من
نقطة التطابق لذلك سنبقي آذاننا
مفتوحة  هذا الاستدعاء الحرج
من dale uh works msa on rx ops
orex قد عالج
عدم اليقين في موضع صورته التالية مترًا واحدًا ، حسنًا ،
نعود إلى متر واحد من
عدم اليقين الموضعي ، وهذا خبر رائع ،
لذا عدنا إلى عينة التحقق أم
سنفعل بعد ذلك '  إعادة بعيدًا جدًا عن الكويكب
و e  لقد استقر كل شيء نوعًا
ما لدينا تلك الذراع الآلية
التي سنستخدمها بالفعل لوضع رأس علامة سام
في مجال رؤية
كاميرا سام ويمكننا أن ننظر ليس فقط إلى الجزء
العلوي من رأس جهاز أخذ العينات كما لو كنا
سنحصل على الصور اليوم ولكن يمكننا في
الواقع
قلبها ويمكننا إلقاء نظرة على قاعدة علامة سام
التي لدينا بالإضافة إلى
تحفيز الغاز لدينا
منصات تلامس ببساطة عن طريق الاتصال
بسطح الكويكب الذي نعتقد أنه
يمكننا التقاطه  جزيئات حبيبات دقيقة
أقل من ملليمتر أو نحو ذلك ،
لكننا في الأساس سنبحث عن
أي دليل على وجود مادة كويكب
داخل أو داخل العلامة ، من الواضح الآن
أنك لا تريد العودة إلى
القول الأول في عمليات orex  اكتمل احتراق نقطة المطابقة ،
حسنًا ، نحن نتجه نحو الأسفل ، لدينا
حوالي 10 دقائق
قبل ملامسة سطح الكويكب ،
يا للروعة ، لذلك كنت على وشك أن أقول إنه من
الواضح أنك لا تريد العودة إلى
الأرض مع عدم وجود الكثير من العينات
كيف تعرف مقدار العينة التي تعمل بها  حصلنا
على تجربة فيزيائية ذكية بشكل لا يصدق
صممها الفريق
هنا تسمى قياس كتلة العينة ،
لذا ما سنفعله هو أننا
سنضع ذراع المركبة الفضائية إلى
جانب المركبة الفضائية ،
لذلك عندما تكون في تكوين أخذ العينات
لقد أشرنا بالفعل أعلاه
إلى هذا وضعناه في الاتجاه الآخر
وقمنا نوعًا ما بتدوير المركبة
الفضائية بأكملها ونقيس خاصية
تسمى لحظة القصور الذاتي التي
فعلناها بالفعل قبل بدء
تسلسل العلامات اليوم
لذلك نحن  تعرف ما هي هذه الخاصية عندما
يكون رأس علامة سام فارغًا
الآن سنكون قادرين على القيام بذلك على
أمل عندما يكون مليئًا بثرى الكويكب ،
لذلك نحن نبحث فقط عن
اختلافات صغيرة في هذه الخاصية
كنتيجة لهذه التجربة و
الدقة تمامًا مثل كل شيء في هذا
البرنامج استثنائية ، فنحن نتحدث عن عشرات
الجرامات من الدقة على قياس
على مركبة فضائية على بعد مئات الملايين من
الأميال ، آه ، لقد التقطت هذا للتو
عينة كويكب
الحد الأدنى الذي نبحث عنه هو 60
جرامًا أو
تحول نظام التحكم في موقف العذر
إلى وضع اللمس والذهاب
للمركبة الفضائية اليمنى تستعد
للاتصال بسطح الكويكب هنا ،
لذا سيخبرنا قياس كتلة العينة
إذا كان لدينا 60  جرامات أو أكثر من
المواد
وسيحدث ذلك يوم السبت في وقت لاحق من
هذا الأسبوع ،
حسنًا ، حسنًا يا دانتي ، هذا أنت تعلم أن
المحركات أعطتنا دفعة في
الاتجاه الصحيح وأن أوزيريس ريكس في
طريقه للهبوط على كويكب
لذلك نحن  سأستمع إلى
مكالمات وحدة التحكم في الرحلة من MSA ولكن قبل
أن نلمس السطح فعليًا ، إنه
وقت رائع لزيارة مكتب وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
مرة أخرى ، لذا
جيمس ما الذي يحدث ، شكرًا
ميشيل ، لذلك كنت تسمع هذه
النداءات من دايل على صوت عالٍ
مكبرات الصوت
حول معالجة هذه الصور nft
سيكون من الرائع الحصول على كاميرا بالفعل
والقيام برحلة إلى bennu
لتصويرها عن قرب شخصيًا
ولكنك تعلم كما ذكرنا bennu
بعيد قليلاً عنا الآن
في حدود 200 مليون ميل
ولكن لا تقلق ،
فهناك شيء يمكن أن يقدمه لك Osiris-rex
الآن من منزلك المريح
إذا كنت تستخدم instagram ، يمكنك التوجه
إلى في نظام ناسا الشمسي ،
لدينا مرشحين ar يمكنك استخدامهما
في قصص وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الخاصة بك ،
هذا المرشح الأول يسمى osiris-rex in
u ويتميز بعلامة لعب osiris-rex مع
bennu حول رأسك ، والمرشح
الثاني يسمى bennu
والعودة  يسمح لك بوضع كويكب
أينما كنت
في المنزل في المدرسة ، أحضر كويكبًا
معك ،
لذلك أفهم أن لدينا بالفعل
سؤالًا قادمًا من instagram من
موريسيو
الذي يسأل كيف يمكنك إدارة
القوة من ملامستها لأسفل ،
أعني اللحظة التي  تلامس المركبة الفضائية
السطح ، يجب أن تواجه
قوة مماثلة في الاتجاه المعاكس ،
كيف تدير ذلك جيدًا بفضل
موريسيو ، لذلك فكر الفريق حقًا
في هذا الأمر عند تصميم تلك العينة التي
أضافوها بالفعل  هذه
الآلية التي تشبه الزنبرك والتي يمكنك التفكير فيها
قليلاً مثل عصا البوجو
إذا كانت عينة الذراع جامدة عند
الاتصال
ببينو ، فستوقف حركتها إلى أسفل
وعند إطلاق زجاجة الغاز لتحريك
عينة ،
سنقوم فقط بالرجوع للخلف  في
الفضاء كما ذكرنا في
وقت سابق ،
ولكن بما أن لدينا ذلك الربيع ، يمكنك
التفكير في الأمر مثل عصا البوجو
عندما تتلامس مع
الأرض ، تبدأ الينابيع في الانضغاط
وتحافظ على حركتك لأسفل ،
إنه نفس الشيء بالضبط ينطبق على
أوزوريس-  rex عندما نتصل بالمكان ،
نستمر في التحرك نحو
الأسفل وعندما نطلق زجاجات الغاز التي تؤدي في
الواقع إلى إبطاء حركتنا نحو الأسفل ،
مما يمنحنا وقتًا كافيًا على
السطح في حدود 10 ثوانٍ
لتحريك عينة قبل أن نبدأ في
العودة إلى الفضاء
لذلك ، إذا كنت تريد حقًا أن ترى
كيف سيبدو حدث العلامة عن
قرب شخصيًا ،
فقد أصدرنا بالفعل فيديو 360 رائعًا حقًا
على صفحة nasa goddard youtube التي
توقفك تمامًا  لم يقم أي شيء من
orex بمعالجة
عدم اليقين في موضع صورته التالية
وهو 0.5 متر ، واو واو واو ، لذا فهذه
تفاصيل عالية حقًا في الوقت الحالي ،
فنحن نقترب حقًا من
السطح
ومرة أخرى كما كنت أقول إذا كنت تريد تج
بة ما سي
دث  تبدو قريبة ،
اركن نفسك على سطح
العندليب وانظر حول هذه
التضاريس بأكملها تم إنشاؤها بالفعل باستخدام
بيانات التضاريس الحقيقية بدقة تصل إلى 2 سم
لكل
بكسل وكما ذكرنا سابقًا بشكل
ربع سنوي ، فهي في الواقع
دقة أعلى مما قمنا بتصويره بالفعل.
تمتلك صورًا جميلة جدًا للأرض والقمر
حقًا
ونشجعك بالتأكيد على التحقق من ذلك ،
لكننا على بعد دقائق فقط من
حدوث ذلك في الواقع في الحياة الواقعية ،
لذلك دعونا نعيدها إليك ميشيل ،
حسنًا ، شكرًا جيمس لذا أه دانتي أريد
ذلك  أطرح عليك بضعة
أسئلة شخصية هنا ، لقد
قضيت حوالي ثلث حياتك في العمل
في هذه المهمة ،
ما الذي تشعر به الآن أه إنه أمر
رائع حقًا  الحالة العاطفية
ميشيل عندما تصل إلى نقطة مثل
هذه في حياتك المهنية ، وهو حدث
عملت من
أجله في حالتي على مدار 16 عامًا للوصول إلى هنا ،
يمكنك إعادة التفكير في كل الأشخاص
الذين ساعدوك على ما أفكر فيه
أعرف عائلتي أنهم يشاهدون
من توكسون أريزونا في الوقت الحالي ، لقد
كانوا مهمين حقًا بالنسبة
لي وشخص آخر لا يمكنه أن يكون معنا
هنا الليلة للأسف هو معلمي
الدكتور مايكل دريك
، وهو الشخص الذي دعاني إلى هذا
البرنامج في  2004
لكي أكون نائبه كنت أستاذًا مساعدًا شابًا
ساطع العينين
وعملنا معًا لمدة سبع سنوات في
كتابة المقترحات أه لإقناع ناسا
أن هذا كان برنامجًا للطيران
إلى حدود جديدة 3. فزنا
بعقد أوزوريس ريكس في مايو  عام 2011 وتوفي مايك في
سبتمبر / أيلول
ضربة حقيقية للفريق لذا أفتقده
وأتمنى لو كان هنا اليوم ،
نعم ، إنه حقيقي جدًا ، أعني أنك تعلم
أننا
مرتبطون بأفاتارنا التي وضعناها
هناك في الكون نعم  نعم
أعلم أنه سيفخر بنا
نعم وسيحبها حقًا أن
تكون معنا الآن ،
لذا فنحن ننظر إلى نوع من محاكاة آه مذهلة في
الوقت الحالي ، لذا تعلم كما
ذكرنا من قبل أن
هذه ليست صورًا فعلية من
مركبة فضائية ولكنها تستند إلى
قدر كبير  من البيانات الحقيقية ،
لذلك نحن في الواقع ننظر إلى أسفل حيث
تبدأ أداة وسم علامة آه هذه في الاقتراب من
موقعها النموذجي ،
نعم ، نحن
نجمع الكثير من الصور الآن ولكننا ببساطة
لا نملك معدل البيانات
لإعادتها إلى الأرض في  في الوقت الفعلي حتى
يتم إيداعهم في
ذاكرة المركبة
الفضائية وسنبدأ في النظر
إليهم لاحقًا الليلة
ونوفرهم للجميع صباح الغد ،
لذا فهذه مجرد محاكاة
لمجال رؤية كاميرا sam
أخذ العينات  الكاميرا
جزء من مجموعة الكاميرا الخاصة بنا ، وهي تحتوي على
لقطة واضحة لمجمع العلامة sam
في منتصف
مجال رؤيتها ، يمكنك في الواقع رؤية
الطرف السفلي من ذراع العلامة sam
هنا ، ينخفض overx msa على orexos orex
لى أقل من 25 ميتًا  حسنًا ،
لقد
اقتربنا حقًا ، أريد أن أذكرك
أنه العبور الذي يبلغ ارتفاعه خمسة أمتار ،
وهذا هو المعبر الحاسم حقًا ، فنحن على
بعد دقيقتين فقط من ذلك ،
لذا فإن المركبة الفضائية لديها قرار رئيسي واحد
متبقي
لجعلها تحسب الآن
احتمالية سقوطها
إما في منطقة خطرة كما حددناها
في خريطة الخطر هذه أو في منطقة آمنة ،
لذلك قد نقرر المركبة الفضائية على ارتفاع خمسة أمتار
أنها خطيرة وستتراجع ،
مما يسمح لنا بالعيش في علامة أخرى
اليوم بالنسبة لي ،
كل ما عندي من حواسي على هذه المكالمة
الآن أريد حقًا أن أسمع
أننا نذهب للحصول على علامة لذلك هذا على بعد
دقيقتين فقط هنا وتذكر بالطبع
أن هذا كان مخططًا لذلك
هذا صحيح ، وإلا فسيتم
للنسخ الاحتياطي والمحاولة مرة أخرى ،
فهذه هي الطريقة التي نحل بها التحديات المذهلة التي قدمها لنا سطح الكويكب هذا ، يمكنك أن ترى هنا أن هذه أرض شاقة جدًا
نأتي إليها هنا
.  صخور النمل في جميع أنحاء
موقع العندليب حتى بعض الصخور الكبيرة
داخل الحفرة التي لا
نعتقد أن المركبة الفضائية ستنجو على
الأقل مع القدرة على العودة إلى
الأرض إذا اتصلت ،
لذا فهي موجودة لحماية نفسها أولاً
وقبل كل شيء
تكون السلامة دائمًا  أولاً أه لكننا
نشعر بأن كل شيء سار على
ما يرام اليوم ، لذا أود أن أقول إن
الأشياء تبدو رائعة للحصول على
علامة ولكن بالطبع المركبة الفضائية
هي التي تتخذ هذا القرار ،
إنه لأمر مدهش أننا كنا نتدرب على
هذا  حدث تعرفه طوال الأسبوع عن جميع
مكالمات المهمة والمعالم المختلفة ولكن بعد ذلك
ستكون هنا الليلة بالفعل
وتدرك أن هذا يحدث على بعد 200
مليون ميل وهذا صحيح ،
أنا متحمس جدًا
لذلك أعني أنه من الواضح أنه كان هناك الكثير من
الأشياء الأولى في  هذه المهمة msa على orexops
orex قامت بمعالجة
حالة عدم اليقين الخاصة بالرسالة التالية وهي 0.5 متر ،
الإزاحة الجانبية المتوقعة للعلامة 1.7
متر ،
احتمالية الخطر صفر بالمائة
ag  المدينة 0.2
ملم في الثانية ، والسرعة العمودية
10.2 سم في الثانية ،
وهذا يبدو جيدًا حقًا ، لذا
يبدو أن حساب خريطة الخطر
يبدو جيدًا حقًا في
أننا سنهبط على منطقة خضراء
سنقوم بالاتصال
بالكويكب  آه ،
تذكر جيدًا كيف كانت هذه هي
مهمة ناسا الأولى لاسترداد
عينة من
كويكب جزء أصلي من النظام الشمسي ، فقط
انظر إلى تلك الرسوم المتحركة الآن ،
لذلك نحن ننظر إلى
الفريق وأعتقد أنه يمكننا رؤية
الجميع  يركز الليزر على
ما ستفعله المركبة الفضائية ،
وأقول دعونا ندع هذا يحدث ،
لكن تلك المكالمات كانت رائعة حقًا
وكانت أخبارًا رائعة من ديل ، نعم
أكثر دقة مما كنا نأمله
في بعض الحالات ،
يبدو الجميع سعداء ، نعم
لذلك أنا  أعتقد أنك تعلم أنه كان من الواضح أنه كان
هناك الكثير من الأشياء الأولى في هذه المهمة
وكان هناك وقت قلت فيه إنك
تعرف الكثير مما إذا كنت تعرف
أساسًا ماذا لو كان بإمكاننا بالفعل إرسال
مركبة فضائية
إلى كويكب ، ماذا لو تمكنا حقًا من
إعادة عينة من النظام الشمسي
من بلايين السنين ،
هل تتذكر أين كنت عندما
هبط هؤلاء ماذا - لو msa على rxops
orex إلى ما دون علامة الخمسة أمتار ،
فإن خريطة الخطر تذهب إليه  تم الإعلان عن العلامة
المتوقعة في غضون 50 ثانية عند
الهبوط ، حيث تم الإعلان عن أن
جميع العينات الصحيحة قيد التقدم
[تصفيق]
يا إلهي ، نحن هناك أناس
رائعون أعني أنني لا أعرف ما إذا كنت قد
رأيت الفريق هنا ولكنهم انفجروا نوعًا
ما  لقد تحولوا من مجرد أعين فولاذية إلى
الإعجاب
بالاحتفال بالسوبر باول ، لذلك
كل شيء جيد ،
هذا رائع ، لذا تهانينا
للجميع أعلم أن
دانتي والدكتور بروكين موجودون هنا ودانتي ، لقد
وصلت إلى هنا بطريقة ما ، تهانينا سريعة جدًا
كيف تشعرون يا رفاق.
أعني أنني لا أصدق أننا فعلنا
هذا الأمر وأنا متحمس جدًا بشأن الفريق الذي
قد يفعله إذا طرحت شيئًا من
فضلك صديقنا مايك دريك
معنا الآن هذا صحيح
لقد أتيت مع ميسي  في
البداية واه نحن نفكر فيه
أنه لم يعد موجودًا على الأرض ولكني أشعر به
هنا وأنا أتفق معنا
اليوم وأنا أعلم أنه فخور للغاية بهذا
الفريق وكل ما أنجزناه
هذا هو التاريخ
أه إنه مذهل أنا  بالكاد أستطيع التحدث إليك
أعلم أنني أحب أن أهزك ماذا عنك ،
نعم بالتأكيد أه من الصعب تقريبًا
معالجة
كل ما يحدث الآن
إنه فخر
كبير بهذا الفريق وكل ما فعلناه
للوصول إلى هنا
أه لم أستطع فعلاً فعل ذلك  أي شيء
أفضل لأقوله عن هذه المجموعة من الأشخاص
يمكنني أن أؤكد أن معدل الرجوع
هو orex msa في مجموعة عينات orac العلوية
قد اكتمل
وأن النسخ الاحتياطي قد نفذ
[تصفيق]
dante التي كانت في الواقع
مكالمة مهمة حقًا كنا نحتفل بها
على العلامة
ربما كان هذا في الواقع أكثر
أهمية ، والذي يُدعى لماذا يتم إطلاق زجاجة بايرو
حتى يتم تشغيل تاغ سام ، حيث
يتم إطلاق الدافع الخلفي ، لذلك نحن نتحرك بأمان
بعيدًا عن سطح الكويكب
، والمركبة الفضائية  فعلنا كل ما كان من
المفترض القيام به ،
لذلك قمنا بذلك ، قمنا بوضع علامات على
سطح الكويكب
، والأمر متروك لبينو الآن لمعرفة كيف
سار الحدث ،
ماذا يعني هذا بالنسبة لناسا ، أعني أن
هذا هو
الانهيار الرئيسي لهذا الآن إنه عدد قليل  أيام
الحق لمعرفة مقدار ما حصلنا عليه
من هذا المثال المذهل ،
صحيح
[تصفيق]
يا إلهي ، يا إلهي
حسنًا ، لقد أخبرك أن هذا
كان يومًا رائعًا رحلة رائعة
نحن فخورون جدًا بكليهما  لك لوجودك
هنا ودعم هذا الفريق ،
سنعود إلى
المسرح وميشيل ، لكن
بعض الأخبار الجيدة حقًا ، لذا نعود إليك
ميشيل ، شكرًا لك ،
هذه واحدة من تلك اللحظات التي نعلم جميعًا
بكوبيا 19 لأنني أريد
العناق والحفلات الخمسية وكل شيء ،
لكننا سنحافظ جميعًا على سلامة بعضنا البعض ،
لكن هناك الكثير من الأشخاص المتحمسين للغاية في
كل مكان والذين يرغبون في المشاركة في
هذه اللحظة
ومشاركة تهانيهم ، لذلك
دعونا نتوقف لحظة لسماع بضع كلمات  من
ثلاثة قادة مؤسسيين ث  لم
أستطع التواجد هنا الليلة
لكنهم يهتفون للفريق
نيابة عن العديد من
المشجعين ، مرحباً بالجميع ، مدير مركز دينيس أندرسون جودارد ،
أنا متحمس جدًا لأن أوزيريس ريكس
يجمع عينة من
سطح الجهاز الجديد  العلامة هي
فقط ذروة المهمة ، لذا
صحح MSA في
مهاراتك في إدارة المشروع باعتباره pi
فقط
ثريًا رائعًا لفريق العمليات للوصول بنا
إلى ما نحن فيه وليزا في ليزا
كالاهان لفريق Lockheed Martin الرائع
أه في الحصول على Osiris-rex  إلى حيث
نحن ونبني مركبة فضائية رائعة
ونعيدها إلى الأرض ،
اذهب سايروس ريكس
اليوم يوم مثير حيث يبدأ أوزيريس ريكس
نزوله إلى
بينو تتطلع الأمة إلى
أخبار حدث ناجح للعلامة التجارية
أوزيريس-ريكس كان أعضاء فريق أوزيريس ريكس
العمل في هذا المشروع لأكثر من
عقد والعمل الذي يتم إنجازه صعب
ومعقد ومن الضروري
فهم تركيبة بينو
سيساعدنا على فهم عالمنا بشكل أفضل
وكيف  o حماية أهم
أصولنا في الأرض الفضائية ،
أود أن أتمنى حظًا سعيدًا
لفريق Osiris-rex بأكمله
بما في ذلك شركائنا في
مركز رحلات الفضاء ناسا جودارد
بجامعة أريزونا وخاصة
مشغلي المهمة والمهندسين
هنا
في لوكهيد مارتن
إن جامعة أريزونا فخورة بشكل لا يصدق
بتقاليدها الطويلة من
التميز والريادة في استكشاف الفضاء ،
ويسعدني أن أرى إنجازات مهام أوزيريس-ركس
تحمل
هذا التقليد لليوم مع ناسا
لوكهيد مارتن وجميع شركائنا الرائعين
تهانينا للجميع  من أعضاء فريق مهمة Osiris-rex ،
لقد أوضحت للعالم كيف
يمكن لإبداعنا وموهبتنا العزيمة
تطوير قدرات أمتنا بأكملها
ولا أطيق الانتظار للعلم المذهل
الذي سنراه
مع العينة المرتجعة في عام 2023
حسنًا ، حسنًا ، نحن  هنا مباشر بعد بعض
الأخبار الممتازة ، أنا هنا مع
دانتي لوريتا المبتهج من جامعة
أريزونا ، لذا مرة أخرى
يشرح جمهورنا عندما نعلم أنه سيكون لدينا عينة
غارقة قليلاً الآن ميشيل ،
يجب أن أقول إنها كانت مكثفة للغاية
لعدة دقائق هنا يمكنني أن أخبرك أن
كل شيء سار على
ما يرام تمامًا وهو نوع
من السمة المميزة لهذا  فريق
أه لقد تغلبنا باستمرار
على التوقعات مرارًا وتكرارًا ،
لقد تغلبنا على التحديات المذهلة
التي ألقى بها هذا الكويكب علينا
ويبدو أن المركبة الفضائية
عملت بشكل لا تشوبه شائبة ،
لقد وصلنا إلى سطح الكويكب ،
كنا على
اتصال بزجاجات الغاز التي تم إطلاقها.  لا أعرف كم من الوقت
كنا على اتصال مع هذه
بعض المعلومات التي أعيد بناؤها والتي
سنضطر إلى تجميعها معًا خلال
الساعات القليلة القادمة مع وصول البيانات ،
فقد ابتعدنا بنجاح عن
سطح الكويكب
، وكان الفريق مليئًا بالعواطف هناك
عالية ،
الجميع فخور حقًا
ولدينا بعض العمل الذي يجب القيام به أه لتحديد
مقدار العينة التي
جمعناها أه الشيء التالي الذي سأكون عليه
هل تبحث عن أه بمجرد أن تبرد المركبة الفضائية
من المحتمل أن تكون دافئة جدًا مع
اقترابها من سطح الكويكب ، لذا فهي
بحاجة إلى التخلص من بعض هذه
الحرارة الزائدة ، يجب إعادة تلك المصفوفات الشمسية
إلى الشمس
والحصول على طاقة موجبة بمجرد
استقرارها  ستشير إلى أن
الهوائي عالي الكسب على الأرض
وسنبدأ في إعادة هذه البيانات
وستخبرنا صور sam cam هذه
بكمية هائلة من
المعلومات حول كيف
سارت أحداث اليوم.
بالنظر إلى سلسلة كاملة
من الصور عندما نزلنا
إلى السطح ، تسبب
الاتصال بإطلاق زجاجة الغاز هذه
وأريد حقًا معرفة كيفية استجابة هذا السطح
، لم نقم بذلك من قبل ، لذا فهذه منطقة
جديدة لنا وللفريق العلمي بأكمله  أعلم
أنه يتطلع حقًا إلى تلك
المعلومات
أه لشيء واحد سيخبرنا
باحتمالية
جمع عينة نوعًا من
التقييم الاحتمالي على
الأرجح الكثير من العلوم التي
تخرج من ذلك أيضًا نعم  حسنًا ، اسمع ،
أعلم أنك تريد العودة إلى هناك مع
فريقك ، ستكون ليلة طويلة
سعيدة ، آمل أن تكون سعيدة لكم جميعًا ، حيث
تأتي المزيد من البيانات ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لكم ، لقد كان
شرفًا كبيرًا أن أكون معك ، شكرًا لكم
جميعًا ، شكرًا لكم جميعًا على  لأمسية رائعة
وأهلاً لهذا الفريق ، إنها تجربة مدهشة
وتم صنع التاريخ الليلة تمامًا
حتى تعرف أن ما سنفعله الآن
هو في الواقع إلقاء نظرة فاحصة على هذه
التضاريس الجميلة التي أخذنا
عينات منها بالفعل
.  لقد حددنا أكثر من مليون
كويكب في النظام الشمسي
ولكن تذكر أن بينو هو ما يسمى
نيو كويكب قريب من الأرض ،
لذا فبدلاً من الدوران في
حزام الكويكبات الرئيسي بين المريخ والمشتري ،
يكون له مدار مشابه إلى حد ما
لكوكبنا الأرض وليس  يحظى باهتمامنا فقط
لأنه قريب جدًا من الأرض ولكن أيضًا
لأننا نعتقد أنه قد يكون أحد
الأجرام القديمة في النظام الشمسي الذي يحتوي على
ثروة من المعلومات
حول كيفية بدء النظام الشمسي والحياة ،
فلنلقِ نظرة أقرب  حسنًا ، في
موضوع كل هذا النشاط ، كل هذه
الفرحة الليلة ، شكرًا لك ،
لنقم بجولة
في ديسمبر 2018 بعد السفر لمدة عامين ،
وصلت 101 يومًا في أكثر من 1.2 مليار ميل من مركبة الفضاء أوزيريس ريكس
التابعة لناسا إلى هدفها
القريب من كوكب الأرض بينو أوزيريس  -ريكس
هي المهمة الأولى لاستكشاف هذه
البقايا البدائية من أصول
النظام الشمسي
المصمم لدراسة الكويكب
وإعادة عينة إلى الأرض.
مركبة فضائية
قبل وصولها ، كان من المعروف أن لديها
خمول حراري منخفض ،
وهي سمة من سمات
المواد الدقيقة مثل الرمل
ومطياف الأشعة تحت الحمراء على أوزيريس ريكس ،
وأكدت هذه الخاصية
مما دفع العلماء إلى توقع
سطح أملس في الغالب
ولكن أول مناظر قريبة لبينو تم
تسليمها  مفاجأة كبيرة
بتفاصيل رائعة ،
كشفت كاميرات البعثة عن
مشهد صخري لا هوادة فيه تهيمن عليه الصخور من خلال
الجمع بين هذه الصور من  أوزيريس ريكس
ببيانات قياس الارتفاع بالليزر الخاصة بها ، يمكننا
القيام بجولة في تضاريس بينو الرائعة
، المحطة الأولى هي سيمريج ساكسون هذه
الصخرة البارزة التي
تحدد خط الزوال الرئيسي للكويكبات
وتعمل كأساس لنظام الإحداثيات
الخاص بها
في الأساطير الفارسية.
الطائر
والمالك لكل المعرفة الساكسون
هو لاتيني للحجر
إلى الشمال الشرقي تقع أكبر
صخرة على بينو
يبلغ طولها أكثر من 300 قدم ، حيث يبلغ طول الصخر الصخري أكثر من 300 قدم
، حيث يعد الساكسون عملاقًا أطول من ملعب كرة القدم
، كما أنه غني بنوع من أكسيد الحديد
يسمى
المغنتيت الذي  تم استخدامه من قبل البحارة
كشكل مبكر
من البوصلة المغناطيسية في الفولكلور العربي ، فإن
الصخرة هي طائر ضخم من الفريسة
يمكنه حبس الأفيال في مخالبها
وكذلك البحارة الذين تقطعت بهم السبل
مثل البطل السندباد
المستمر شمال شرقًا فوق التلال الاستوائية
نصل
إلى غرغويل ساكسون هذا  الصخرة المدهشة
هي من بين أحلك الصخور في بينو على الرغم من أنها
تلمس صخرة أكثر إشراقًا
بحجم شخص
في العصور الوسطى  الجرغول الأسطورة عبارة
عن
وحوش مجنحة تشبه التنين يمكنها أن تتنفس النيران
وأن كاتدرائيات الحراسة من الأرواح الشريرة
تأخذنا وجهتنا التالية بعيدًا إلى
الشرق
في الطرف الشمالي من فوهة بركان صغيرة
تقع أسيبيتي ساكسون
صخرة مشرقة نسبيًا
يبلغ قطرها حوالي 33
قدمًا  يقع oscipide saxon
بالقرب من واحد من ثلاثة مواقع
حيث قام بينو بإخراج جزيئات صغيرة إلى
الفضاء في أوائل عام 2019
لعرض طبيعته الديناميكية والمتطورة
في الأساطير اليونانية.
من الأرض
[الموسيقى]
في قصص الخلق في مصر القديمة
،
بدأ الكون كامتداد لا نهاية له من
الماء
من هذا البحر البدائي نشأ
التل البدائي
بن بن ، وعلى هذه الصخرة
استقر خريف الإله على شكل طائر بينو
وأرسلت الدعوة التي شكلت
الخلق قصة بن هاركنز إلى
أكوام الطمي الخصب التي كانت في يوم من الأيام  تتأرجح
من مياه الفيضانات المتراجعة لنهر
النيل وتوفر اسمًا
مناسبًا لأطول صخرة على بينو
بارزة بأكثر من 70 قدمًا من
بينبن ساكسون طويل جدًا لدرجة أنه تم
اكتشافها لأول مرة من الأرض
الآن يمكننا تقدير هذه
الميزة الضخمة بالتفصيل
باستخدام بيانات من  أوزيريس ريكس
[موسيقى]
المحطة الأخيرة في جولتنا عبارة عن مجموعة
من الصخور اللامعة بشكل استثنائي
المنتشرة عبر نصف الكرة الجنوبي
وهي تحمل بصمة طيفية من
البيروكسين ،
وهو معدن موجود في الصخور النارية من غير
المرجح أن يكون قد تشكل على بينو.
على الكويكب الكبير فيستا
وتم تسليمه إلى جسد بينو من
خلال اصطدامات النيازك على
الرغم من صغر حجمه ،
فقد أثبت بينو أنه
عالم رائع وفير في
الميزات الجغرافية
التي تحدت توقعاتنا
بفضل أوزوريس ريكس
يمكننا الآن استكشاف بينو  كشف تكوينه
وتطوره وذكرياته القديمة
من
أصول النظام الشمسي
[موسيقى].
إذا سارت الأمور على ما يرام الليلة ،
فسيعود القليل من بينو
إلى الأرض في عام 2023.
لذلك دعونا نحصل على زيارة أخيرة مع
مكتب وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لدينا جيمس ما الذي يحدث ،
نعم ميشيل ، لدي قشعريرة
لا يمكنني حتى البدء في ذلك  فهم
أننا وضعنا
علامة للتو وجمعنا عينة من هذا
الكويكب على بعد 200 مليون ميل ،
وأنا أعلم أنني سأرغب في إعادة إحياء
الأحداث التي تكشفت الليلة ، وأنا
متأكد من أنك ستفعل ذلك أيضًا ، لذا لدينا مرة أخرى
هذا الفيديو بزاوية 360 درجة  انتقل إلى
صفحة دليل ناسا على youtube
لتتفقدها وتضع نفسك في
المكان الذي حدث فيه الحدث
قبل دقيقتين ،
إنه أمر مذهل حقًا ،
وأريد أيضًا التحقق مرة أخرى من خلال
استطلاع Twitter الذي وضعناه في
بداية البث
و  نسألكم عن كمية المواد
التي تعتقدون أننا حصلنا عليها للتو من الكويكب
بينو ،
لذا تذكروا أننا نبحث عن 60 جرامًا على الأقل ،
لكن حاوية العينة هذه يمكن أن
تستوعب ما يصل إلى كيلوغرامين ، لذا
تقولون يا رفاق ذلك مثل
عينة بحجم قالب حلوى
أنا  مثل التفاؤل ، فلنأمل
أن نحزم هذه الحاوية إلى أقصى حد
ونعيد كل العينة إلى المنزل ، لكن
أي عينة نحصل عليها هي سحرية حقًا وستساعدنا في
معرفة المزيد عن النظام
الشمسي وأصولنا هنا ،
لذا تابعونا على الهاشتاج  إلى bendu والعودة ،
نحن متحمسون لمواصلة هذه
المحادثة حيث نتطلع إلى إحضار
هذه العينة طوال الطريق من بينو
هنا إلى الأرض في عام 2023 ، لذا شكرًا لك
ميشيل ،
هذه إحدى هذه الأمسيات حيث يكون
هذا امتيازًا وسعادة
للعمل من أجل ناسا ومن أجل فكرة
الاستكشاف العلمي ،
لذا فإن ما كنا نفعله طوال المساء هو
رؤية فرحة رؤية هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين
عملوا على هذا الأمر لعقود من الزمن ،
لكن عليك أن تتذكر أن هناك سببًا حقيقيًا
لأننا سنبحث  في هذه
الكويكبات ،
نعتقد أننا في الواقع قد
نعود مع صورة طفل
لما كان عليه النظام الشمسي
لما كانت عليه
كيمياءنا منذ بلايين السنين ونحن نبحث عن
أصولنا الخاصة هناك وهذا هو السبب في أننا
لقد
ذهبنا بعيدًا لاستعادة القليل من البينو ،
لقد كان هذا أمسية رائعة ، حيث
بدأ الأدرينالين في
الانخفاض ببطء ، وسيكون هناك
الكثير من الاحتفال والكثير من العمل
في الساعات القادمة ، لذا من لوكهيد
مارتن  الفضاء هنا في ليتلتون كولورادو
أنا الدكتورة ميشيل ثالر تصبح على خير